foreign
in Columbus Ohio what's up Caitlyn
hi how we doing
I'm all right how are you good good good
good
okay so
um
to get some context here
you called in on another show I was
um on the Ramsey show you called in and
you were talking about boundaries with
your mom is that right
yep okay walking me through the original
call here
okay and then and what I what the advice
I gave because it may have been terrible
advice
essentially since I graduated high
school my mom has been asking me for
money
um
and I'm just feeling kind of over it and
um so but my mom doesn't have a very
good income she has a very low income so
I can't just not give her anything so
your advice was to
um pay a bill directly to the company
and tell her like I'm taking this over
but I'm not giving you any more money
I'm not giving any money directly to her
okay and I don't know if we talked about
this but why does she choose to make
an income that she can't live on
so she yeah I forgot to recap that part
um she's on disability so she
Sorter and her knees are horrible
because my brother beat her that's right
that's right that's right so there's
some family violence in there and then
um so she's on a fixed income but if I
remember correctly does she spend a lot
he just she doesn't even have that much
money but she spends all of the money
she doesn't have like I'll give you an
example here in a minute when I tell you
my new problems okay okay
so basically I I told you hey if it was
my mom I'd continue to help her out but
clearly just handing her cash is not
helping the problem so instead of
handing somebody cash
I will take care of one bill or two
bills or whatever but I'm gonna I'm
gonna pay directly to the company I'm
gonna take this burden off of you
okay and so bring me that now we're up
to speed so what's happened since then
okay so a few days after that I I don't
live in this same city as my mom so I
drove down and like sat her down and we
went through her expenses we went
through her income we I downloaded every
dollar we talked about like Mom you have
to budget like look you just don't have
enough money right now because you're
spending here and here and here and
um I told her I would take over some of
the bills and I think the phrase that I
used was
I'm paying this
but that is it I cannot be your
emergency fund anymore
um can I just stop real quick good for
like good for you that's that was a hard
conversation wasn't it
yeah I was so stressed about it I think
I listened to our call on the Ramsey
Show like five times right before
they're like get all pumped up before
you survives though yeah you were like
Dwight in the Camaro listening to Motley
Crue just like getting ready good job
yes all right good job okay so you had
this call conversation how did it how
did she take it in person initially
he it seemed to go well I mean she was
that and embarrassed
um
but she seemed receptive
and my sister was there too my sister
lives with her and also just gives her
money all the time and so I talk to my
sister too about like I know you live
together and you don't pay rent but you
need to come up with like a set number
that you're paying her every month not
just like swipe my card when you run out
just not be an ATM machine good for you
gosh good for you okay so
I'm assuming that sounded good in
philosophy and in theory but then in
reality has been different
yeah so we had that conversation seemed
to be good I set up to pay a couple of
her bills
um
and then
literally the next week he is calling me
hey do you want to go to a concert
together I just bought tickets
so that was very frustrating yes so
frustrating so now she's got she's got a
little bit of room to breathe and
she chose to buy concert tickets right
yeah and I don't think they were
insanely expensive but like I know they
were more than the amount that we
budgeted for stuff yeah
um and then last week so before I
emailed you guys
um
she called me crying on Thursday
and said like
I'm so sorry to ask you this I know you
said you can't give me any more money
but
um the property taxes are due and I am a
failure and I didn't budget for them
I I need a thousand dollars
oh
I like kind of sat in silenced for a
little bit and she said or I mean if you
could at least do 500 that would help
yeah so you asked me what you should do
now
um Ramsey another show okay yeah
um
so part of the reason that
I'm like kind of done with giving her
all of this money
and I are like aggressively saving to
cash flow fertility stuff
um because we want to be parents and my
mom knows that we've had this
conversation that we're trying to say
about this money so that we can have a
baby
um because it like won't work for us
naturally and
it feels like when she asked me oh gosh
I'm gonna cry it feels like
um
when she asks keeps asking me for money
knowing what we're trying to do with our
money
it feels like she's saying my
desire to not budget is more important
than
you guys being parents yeah and that's
making me feel really resentful and like
I know you always say tooth guilt over
resistance but I'm feeling both yeah
well and let me let me reframe that a
little bit okay
um do you have kids yet
no okay okay yeah that's that's what
you're working on Okay so
I've got two little ones I've got a 13
year old and a seven-year-old okay
I'm trying to imagine what would happen
if on the way home today
I got in a car wreck
and I hit my head just enough that I
couldn't I couldn't talk as quickly as I
can on this show
and ultimately me and my boss me and
Dave had to sit down and say hey um
uh we can't I mean we can't have you on
the radio show anymore
I had to go on disability
and then when I was on disability my 13
year old which is just this is funny
because he's the kindest guy in the
world but he got mad at me with a
baseball bat and broke both of my knees
and I went through rehab again and had
to get on government assistance and I
was on disability and I'm never going to
be what I was and I'm pretty active I'm
out all the time
and so I wanna
I do get the feelings that you have your
feelings are very very real
but just for context I'm gonna imagine
your mom as somebody who's gone through
severe trauma
in her life as she had mapped it out is
nowhere
close to what she thought it was going
to look like
and her body has over time
focused everything on her own belly
button
right
and so yeah I don't think she and this
this may even hurt worse I don't think
she even thinks of you guys
I don't think it even enters her mind
because everything is about the next
second in her life
and because she has
um lost the inability over time to look
up and see out ahead of her and see
other people and experience the people's
lives she just staring at her belly
button belly button belly button it's
all about right now I want to buy these
tickets right now I need a thousand
dollars right now and I just expect the
world to give it to me
because in many ways she's given up on
herself
and I'm going to even say
for some of that fair enough
but eventually
people who give up on themselves do one
of two things either they run out of
options and they decide today's the day
like sick and tired of being sick and
tired right you've heard that
um yeah I'm gonna figure this out or
they spiral out
and so my guess is for the first time
you're putting up some pretty
significant boundaries and you're
choosing your your family
your husband and your in the family that
will be to come
over just being an endless ATM machine
and the way you've done it which is not
just cutting her off and not just saying
forget you you're no we're still going
to honor you you're I'm still gonna
honor my mother and father honoring
doesn't mean I have to do whatever you
say whenever you ask that means I'm
gonna love you the best we can right now
and so I'm gonna pick up one or two
bills
I think that's pretty noble
but I would get
um I would tell you I would get out of
her head as to why she's calling
um what she's not thinking about what
she's trying to do to you and your
husband I would get out of her head
because all that does is weigh you down
yeah it's an exhausting thing to try to
figure out what your mom is thinking
right
yeah and so I would just quit trying to
figure that out and I would stick by our
boundaries and if you and your husband
want to say okay you send us your bill
and I'll tell you this um when people
start budgeting it usually takes about
90 days about three budget Cycles to get
it all ironed out because crap like this
happens like oh I forgot about life
insurance that bill just showed up or I
forget that you know we oil changes have
forgot that
um and so these things just pop up
and so it usually takes about 90 days
three months to get to get to a solid
budget and so it may be that you you sit
down your husband and say hey we're on a
we were we cut off we cut mom off but
there's going to be an exit ramp here
it's gonna be a little bit longer than
we hoped so Mom you send me your tax
bill and me and my husband will decide
because that textbook may not even be
real right
yeah I don't know yeah exactly
so you send me the bill I'll consider it
or you say Mom we're just not going to
do any more money right now
yeah
and um I'll tell you this here's
probably what's going to happen there's
gonna be tears and she sounds like she's
already tried that calling you I'm such
a loser I'm the worst
we help your poor mom
you said no
good for you for holding boundaries and
then it's going to turn into anger how
dare you
who do you think you are who do you
think you are right yeah
I just don't know like
like I saw her yesterday
um
and like I was just like my whole body
was just like tense the whole time and I
don't know if that's because you always
say to like lead with this my Asus
course like a nine so I don't know
um if that's why or like but like I feel
like I get worked up easily but
hold on your body's been trying to
protect you for so long Caitlyn I know
and your mom has never been a place
that's safe
and I want to tell you this she should
have been
I'm not blaming her because it sounds
like the whole world caved in on her too
yeah but your mom's not safe
and so constantly putting your finger
back in the light socket and getting
frustrated to keep getting electrocuted
at some point that's on you
and that means you have to deal with you
have to grieve the picture that I'm
gonna have this new husband who's
amazing we're gonna have a couple of
kids it's gonna be amazing and we're
gonna have Grandma time you may not have
Grandma time
or it may be very limited and very
different than how you had hoped it
would be
and you have to also grieve the fact
that we were just going to start having
babies and that's been a challenge right
yeah and the one person you should be
able to call is your mom and you can't
call Mom
and so that means not that you do
without calling people but now your new
mission is to find a woman who's got
some experience down the road from you
that you can trust that you could reach
out to do you have that
um
Maybe
everything in your body will say don't
take a risk with a maternal figure and
I'm going to tell you you've got to you
need that you're worth that
you see how much how much bigger this
picture gets for you
have you been to counseling yet
yeah
um
I've been in and out of counseling for a
long time but I started going again a
couple months ago
how's that working
[Music]
um
it's good
um I just I haven't been able to see my
person for a couple weeks because she's
been on vacation okay
I want you to get back in as soon as
possible and here's what I want you to
ask in a direct way
I need to work on a boundaries with Mom
and B I need to work on some skills that
when I'm with Mom I stop Outsourcing the
way my body feels
to her energy
that's what healing actually is
is when you can be around somebody who's
not okay and you remain okay
you can remember those things that
happen to you an Aces score of nine
means you grew up in hell right
yeah yeah
that you can think back to some of those
things and your body doesn't take off on
you
I'm gonna tell you being on the other
side of it it's amazing
you trust me that that healing is real
yeah a promise a promise what you've
done with the skill set you've got is
nothing short of Staggering
it's amazing and you don't see it
because you're in the middle of it and
you just feel every time Mom calls or
every time she's around your heart
starts beating really fast
remember this line she does not get a
vote
do you have any close close friends
beside your husband
I have a couple okay I want you to call
them
and I want you to if you can invite him
out for coffee great
if not cool talk to him on the phone and
just say I'm going through a new season
of healing especially as I enter into
IVF and all that stuff which is just an
up and down roller coaster it's brutal
um
and I'm going to need somebody to reach
out to just to say I'm not okay today
and I'm choosing you and I'll hope that
you'll accept that role like like 007.
this I hope you'll accept the mission
and I might text you at midnight I might
text you at 10 A.M
and here's our secret code if I need you
to call me right away
but can I count on you in that way and
they may say no they may say no but I
bet they won't
I bet they'll say absolutely
because you're doing the right things
the hard right things I'm proud of you
but now we're going to move into step
two which is okay we're putting up
boundaries which are great now that
we've got these boundaries up we gotta
get take care of the heartbeat inside
these walls inside these boundaries and
that's you
it's gonna be some intentional
connection with husband that's going to
be some intentional connection with some
friends that's going to be some
intentional disconnection from Mom and
by the way the when the money gets cut
off she'll probably pull away and you're
going to feel a tension that you got to
go find her you don't not in this season
not why you're getting well
because mom's still not safe
and she's gonna get mad she's gonna get
angry all that
mom's not safe
so I'm gonna hold my ground I'm gonna
hold my boundary I'm gonna rely on my
people who I love
I'm proud of you hang on the line I'm
gonna send you building a non-anxious
life too
um that's something you and your husband
can use as a road map inside your home
because you have to build something
you've never seen which is a home full
of laughter and warmth and joy not a
home fill of chaos chaos chaos and abuse
you call anytime we'll we'll I'll be on
the show once a week just have you call
in and check in and see what the latest
thing I can help you with
but I promise you there's healing on the
back into this last thing as I said
earlier be very direct with your
counselor about which one to work on I'm
not just going to go and talk anymore
we're going to get very specific
because I need to learn how to live in
my own skin
and unfortunately I gotta learn to live
in my own skin separate from Mom
I promise you can do it I promise